so in life you and i get judged for a
lot of different things we do who we
marry who we befriend who we follow how
we lead and the products we produce
meaning the great parent is judged based
on
kids they produce who produce great
grandkids right that's our judge so if
you're a leader this message is to
challenge you on how you view the people
that you're leading on a daily basis so
and if by the way the message i give if
it makes sense to your challenges you
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let me get right into it so
say you're somebody that have a has a
right attitude you're uplifting you're
positive you're willing to put the
effort and you're somebody that's got a
person that's trusting right put those
three things into place let's set that
aside a great leader
leads you in the following way there's
three ways people look at you
and below average leader leads you
and thinks about what you did nine
months ago so in the back of their head
even though you got a good attitude even
though you're making the effort even
though you want to get improved
a a below average leader looks at you
and says yeah but man internally yeah
six months ago this guy's not gonna do
anything this guy's not gonna do
anything to always look at your past
that you made a mistake in something
that you did so they can't get past that
so they can't view where you can be an
average leader views you as uh for face
like who you are today so you know what
this guy was good six months ago he's
good today this this is who i see him
being but great leaders have the have
the ability to
look at you
and say let me tell you something johnny
you got a great attitude you make the
effort you you're improving and you made
a lot of mistakes in the past before but
one day i see you
being a leader of great leaders i see
you leading other people i see you one
day being able to xyz so
the focus becomes of who you can be one
day and if you're working with a leader
like that that's encouraging you that
one day you can be this person who
doesn't want to run through the wall for
somebody like that right you just think
about parents when parents like i
remember when you were 14 years they
were doing this mom i'm not 14 anymore
i'm 28 years old making a half a million
dollar income what are you talking about
yeah but when you were 14 it's annoying
right but at the same time is when
you're sitting somebody next to you
that's your leader or your mentor and
they say
you just see him as this let me tell you
what i think this guy's going to do
here's what he's going to be doing he's
going to do boom boom boom boom boom
just be patient watch what happens the
next three to five ten years if
he makes the effort if he stays humble
if he has the right attitude if he keeps
improving this guy's going to be one of
the greatest leaders we see in our
lifetime that's a development that's a
future so either if you're following
someone you have to look for that
language or if you are a leader you have
to start looking at people of who they
can be not just who they are today or
the mistakes they made six months ago
and the main criteria here for some of
you be like my leader doesn't look at me
that way well maybe also because your
attitude isn't that good and you don't
consistently show effort and maybe
because you're not trying to improve
yourself and that's on you that's not on
the leader because that part you control
they don't control desire that's on you
all i'm saying is assume you have this
and i'm looking at who you can be that's
the value so you got to bring the
attitude the effort the improvement
that part the leaders got to say i can i
think one day you can be xyz i've seen a
lot of guys that i've worked with over
the years who had these right criteria
but they kept making small little
mistakes i'm like listen one day this
guy's gonna be a big giant so for you as
a leader you got to look at the people
in that lens and they're going to follow
you and eventually they'll become who
you think they're going to become
if you think they're going to be small
thinking negative complainers that's
exactly what they're going to become if
you think they're going to want to be
leaders that's exactly what they'll
become as well odds are more on your end
to think of who they one day become
rather than who they are today and i got
a video i want you to watch that is even
deeper of this topic it's 10 traits of
leaders word develop and if you've never
watched it
click here to watch that video take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
[Music]